bien à l'abri dans leur boîte ici sur
ses étagères ses pellicules sont les
témoins de l'histoire du cinéma
en tout ce sont plus d'un million de
bobines entreposés sur les deux sites du
cnc de bois d'arcy et du fort de saint
cyr un patrimoine inventorié restaurer
et conservé par le cnc la direction du
patrimoine du centre national du cinéma
et de l'image animée différentes
missions d'abord la conservation des
collections film qui lui sont confiées
dans le cadre de dépôt volontaire c'est
à dire des producteurs des
collectionneurs des laboratoires qui ont
confié des supports filmique donc ses
collections confié vont être inventoriés
vont être surveillés conservés dans de
bonnes conditions
sur ce site de 5 hectares les bobines
sont numérisés restaurer et classés par
support avec trois grands silos de
stockage pour les supports dits de
sécurité
les films sont conservés à une
température moyenne de 10 degrés et un
taux d'humidité de 35 à 45%
le principe d'un centre d'archivés c'est
effectivement de pouvoir accueillir
toutes les expressions on va dire du
cinéma donc on a des films même d'avant
le début du cinéma
on est dans une salle de conservation de
des films sur support de sécurité c'est
à dire sur un support acétate dit à
cette appli polyester c'est la pellicule
qui est aujourd'hui le support de
conservation même du numérique étant
donné qu'on ne sait pas conserver de
façon pérenne le numérique aujourd'hui
la pellicule polyester a une durée de
vie d'à peu près 300 ans
le ce que vous avez dans votre caméra a
priori cette cassette sa durée de vie
elle est peut-être de 5 6 ans dans
d'autres espaces sont conservés les
films les plus anciens sur un support en
nitrates une matière hautement
combustible qui nécessite une
conservation toute particulière là on
est à peu près à entre 10 et 12 degrés
et puis un taux d'humidité un petit peu
plus un peu plus élevé donc voilà ce
qu'il nécessite
les bâtiments type différent on va aller
voir une intérieure d'une cellule
ce sont parfois des trésors inestimables
que l'on peut trouver dans ces cellules
des trésors qui ont parfois plus d'une
centaine d'années comme ce film de 70 mm
des frères lumière tournée lors de
l'exposition universelle dans les
perforations soit un petit peu un petit
peu abîmés mais à part ça l'image et le
support sont encore dans un état
exceptionnel
voilà ce film à 116 ans la collection
nitrates représente environ un tiers de
la totalité des pellicules conserver au
cnc des bobines surveiller sauvegarder
un véritable travail de fourmi car le
patrimoine du cnc ne s'arrête pas
seulement au cinéma